[Music]
you've ever wondered why Disney tales
all end in lies here's what happened
after all their dreams came true hey
guys this is Carly of new media
rockstars today I'm sitting down jon
cozart the creator of the after ever
after parody video and also a youtuber
known as paint hey John how are you
doing today
hi I'm doing great how about yourself
I'm good it's Monday but it's a good
Monday ok good Monday yeah how's classes
been going today
um I'm not any so I'm gonna try to make
the next one I've got one in half an
hour
all right fingers crossed when did you
first start playing music I first
started being in the music when I was
really young my grandma says I I like
hummed gospel music in my cradle which
is a little bizarre before I could speak
Jesus she tells me every time I go over
there so that's it's kind of strange but
besides that I only had like classical
piano music training when I was young
and then I had to quit that when I got
into high school cos it was too
time-consuming and that's about all in
the music front yeah after that when did
you first start writing your own music
um well actually I first started writing
piano music when I was young but I
didn't write lyrics until about high
school and then I would start like I
would write these really elaborate like
love songs to the girls I like it's
actually were super embarrassing and I
would I would like play them for them
and it was like this huge romantic
gesture and that's when I started really
writing lyrics and other music of course
it was totally embarrassing and it never
worked but you know it got me to write
music and I sort of dabble in lyrics
it's not it's okay wait so how did girls
used to react when you would just start
serenading them at school
well I imagine it's like if your little
brother was playing you a nice little
song that's how they reacted you know
it's like oh it's so cute and then
that's about all all they got me but I
think now I'm like having Redemption
because but I mean some for some reason
like parody parroting dizzy Disney I
can't speak that's okay
parroting it's not even a word
singing just singing Disney songs have
been is it's working so it's getting you
the ladies with as a Disney parody plan
yeah there we go
you say it a lot better than I can I was
gonna ask you have you ever gotten a
date from your YouTube channel actually
today there was a girl from my class my
Shakespeare class she's from Britain and
she asked me if we wanted if she if I
were wanna hang out with her and I was
like sure so I mean she asked me which
is another embarrassment but you know
that's sort of a date ish heck yeah
that's a date yeah I'll count it
oh that's so exciting all right will you
enjoy that yeah I hope this I hope she
doesn't see this that would be really
awkward oh well we need to show her
later down the road
um when and why did you decide to start
your own YouTube channel um I first
started making videos when I was in
middle school and I made them for my
classes for like some things like that I
would upload them and then my classmates
would watch them and they were pretty
bad up until about two years ago I
decided to start really taking it
seriously at which point I started
trying to understand what went viral
what was popular things like that so
about two years ago I really started
hammering away at successful formats and
things like that
so what from the time that you started
what have you learned along the way
especially like in the last two years
when you really started to focus on
putting out so much more content there
isn't a formula that you have to sort
every project as if it is going to fail
and just expect it to fail and then if
it's six
you know that's the best-case scenario I
guess along the way what has been your
favorite YouTube video to make
I really enjoyed writing Harry Potter in
99 seconds like that what's probably the
most creative and like fun time I've had
writing a song and I just wrote it in
like a week and I did just the whole
week I was having a ball so that's
probably been the most fun to make and
this one was this the recent one after
ever after it was really fun to record
like the music was really fun to make
because it's Disney so I had a blast
what is your creative process normally
like from when you start writing up the
lyrics to when you finally upload the
video oh gosh I'd say depends on the
video it carries this video probably
took me about three or four months
writing it took me about three weeks I
think and then recording the audio since
it's a 4-minute just acapella music and
you know my voice is throughout the
whole thing it took me about a good
month and a half to record the audio so
it's just like it's super tedious I
arrange everything by ear so if I screw
something up and even a little bit I
just have to go back and rerecord it
it's like really tedious but uh filming
took a day editing took a day and then
the release took a day obviously so um
the hardest parts of the audio yeah I
would imagine what are the challenges of
being a one-man acapella team a
challenges I think is I don't know how
to arrange music very well I've never
been trained in that way so I just have
to sort of hear it and then copy it and
that's the biggest challenge also the
biggest challenge is that it takes four
months for me to make a video so ya know
my audience really hates that but I
can't go any faster so for your future
goals what are you working on now
um right now I'm just I mean I'm doing
interviews and things like that I'm
talking to agents and companies and
things like that I'm seeing where my
future is gonna lie because this is this
is like been a huge platform for me this
latest video but my next video
I don't know and I have a lot of ideas I
think I want to go I want to do another
one on Disney maybe Disney Villains
I'm thinking about it I also might want
to cover some music and put another spin
on it like popular music and that's
where I think I'll go would you want to
go into music as like a full-time
profession if this kind of panned out is
that something you'd consider or are you
thinking more film
I don't think musics in my future I
never I've never thought I had this
really strong voice you know it's just
okay it does what I need it to do and
then that's it so I don't know if music
is my career
but I definitely want to make films I
think that's a really interesting job to
have so if you could collaborate with
any artist alive or dead who would you
choose to collaborate with gosh uh-huh
what a question
um artist
yes musician sure I mean I loved I
listened to classical musical classical
music all the time
although Alan Menken know Stephen
Sondheim that's it okay I would want to
collaborate with Stephen Sondheim okay
nice and if you were to date any cartoon
character who would you pick any cartoon
character what a bizarre question yeah
yeah maybe a humanoid version of Sandy
Cheeks from Sponge Bob okay all right
that's how many I can't think of
anything else right now spongebob is the
bomb so I'll go with that well going at
that one all right and so it's kind of
my final question what advice do you
have for creators who are trying to
build their social media platform on
YouTube um my advice would be just keep
making content because I failed for five
years you know I didn't understand what
YouTube was or I didn't understand what
what kind of audience I was going to
until I made content and I had I've had
a lot more failures than I have had
success success stories so I'd say just
keep making stuff and if people like it
they'll come and if they don't move on
to something else yeah John thank you so
much for sitting down and talking with
us I really appreciate it
no absolutely it's been a blast thanks
agreed yeah good luck learning the class
yeah it's only five o'clock I got it I'm
good yes okay that makes us feel good
yeah thank you so much I can't wait to
see this okay if you've ever wondered
why Disney tales all end in lies here's
what happened after all their dreams
came true
[Music]